hey david between the legal challenges
and the not conceding and claiming he
won and lawsuits
and elector ideas what is donald trump's
actual
end game here does he think he will be
inaugurated to a second term
i think the answer is no i think at this
point donald trump knows he's not
getting a second term
and for me you know there's been a lot
of focus about
trump's lawsuits having the goal
of throwing out so-called illegal votes
or getting a recount that changes the
results
i think if we want to for a second uh
uh believe that there's some bigger
strategy here and there may not be but
let's imagine there is some bigger
strategy the more likely strategy the
more
likely to be effective strategy here
would be
that donald trump is merely trying to
get a court to prevent
a state from certifying its election
if you can prevent state legislatures
from certifying
the election results you then
can create a situation where state
legislators
get to pick electors this is part of
three usc
section two now this is different than
what i talked about
in an earlier segment where i said
you're not going to get enough faithless
electors
you're not going to get willy-nilly
states to just send different electors
but there's this scenario where if you
can actually delay certification
state legislatures get to appoint
electors
and for me if there is a strategy and
i don't know that there is these people
have shown themselves to be incompetent
everything they're filing
is being thrown out if there were a
strategy it would be that
i still think it's unlikely because i
don't know that i
see a court staying in other words
pausing certification by any state
in such a way that it will go further
than uh roughly december 14th which is
when that
electoral vote is set to happen i don't
see that happening courts have been
moving very quickly oftentimes we'll
have a lawsuit and then two days later
the court throws it out courts
understand the time
sensitivity of this um so
given that i don't think trump really
believes he has a shot at overturning
the election results
it seems to me that this is either just
donald trump's delusional narcissistic
ego
who can't admit that he lost even if he
sort of knows he knows he's going to be
pushed out he simply can't admit it and
he says file every lawsuit you can do
everything you can
it might simply be that it could be
donald trump planning to undermine joe
biden not only now but through his
presidency
and this is just part of it never
admitting that he actually lost
it could be that donald trump is trying
to hand joe biden the most chaotic
possible situation he can
on january 20th and continuing to
further
uh these lawsuits is part of that and it
could be that donald trump is simply
trying to smoothly transition
right into some kind of media project
which has been hypothesized by many
trump wants to do
some kind of challenger to fox news some
kind of you know
out foxing fox news with some kind of
trump news network
all of these things i find myself saying
okay we'll deal with that when when we
come to it if we do
after donald trump has left office on
january 20th but i don't see any
end game beyond that and if you really
think donald trump is doing this because
he thinks he's going to get a second
term
i want to hear from you i just don't see
it we have a great bonus show for you
today
after which we will be off thursday and
friday for thanksgiving
i will be back with you on monday monday
have a good holiday
if you're celebrating be safe very
important be safe